we'll stay to the phones stay with the
phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and speaking
of 6 1 7 our next caller is from the 6 1
7 area code maybe here in the Boston
area 6 1 7 go ahead yes my name is
swathi myalgia but everyone calls me Q
alright that's easy what's on your mind
yeah so I have actually a couple of
questions I wanted to talk to you about
just kind of your specifics when you
come up with the stories you do every
single day and I do really appreciate
you and just shout out to your facebook
your facebook videos have been blowing
up I see them every day and I love
seeing them every day so thank you for
that I don't know how you do that my
pleasure um but so like getting to it I
just wanted to know how do you first of
all where do you get the majority of
your information when you're looking you
know what where'd you get the fact
where'd you go for the fact because I
feel like like do you even watch like
the castle in ski do you've been watched
you whitey do we even watch fox news any
of that stuff or is it strictly like
where do you get yourself yeah I barely
watch any I don't really watch any shows
I mean I what if if we're doing a media
critique story I obviously watch the
segment that I'm going to be talking
about but I don't really use any of
those as news sources we try to
basically just use primary sources for
stories so not blogs that are
summarizing what a new source said but
the actual source of news and then in
addition to that we'll do background
research above and beyond on the people
involved or the topic or whatever but no
we I don't really watch any shows and we
don't really build our infrastructure
for stories based on other opinion
programming when following up on that
can I just get like a really short clip
of like how long does that process take
because you put out content I mean it's
like every single day 24/7 all day every
day like how long does that process take
well the production happens each day so
in the afternoon I'll start working on
the next day's stories and then in the
morning I'll continue working on that
day's show and then usually by around
9:00 to 9:30
my part is done and producer Pat picks
it up and starts gathering images and
getting a set up for that day's
production producer Noah will generate
some of the YouTube thumbnails that you
see for the videos and the Facebook
thumbnails will then tape the show in
the afternoon and then typically by 3:30
p.m. or 4 p.m. Eastern Time that show is
out and sort of the process starts all
over again okay so that's awesome last
question thank you so much for doing
this I appreciate this and this is more
content-based so let's make this the
last one to do we do have 25 people
holding oh yeah a lot of you well you're
super it's common you're very objective
when you do your news and I see you very
much as the left version of ben shapiro
where do you how do you feel about that
I'm scared I'm scared by that yeah
that's that's concern if anybody if I'm
the anything version of ben shapiro
that's a scary thing to me ya know I
don't know I mean yeah listen Ben
Shapiro is an effective speaker I don't
agree with his politics but he's an
effective speaker so I guess in some
sense it's a compliment right Pat um you
know there's a lot of similarities
between you two right not particularly
tall or something like that but that's
it all right cue appreciate it very much
thanks for the call good to hear from
cue in the Boston area